found the beast around the case I win
fantastic beasts and where to find them
this was not a movie I was planning to
talk about I saw it a while back end of
November but I didn't do a review on it
at the time and I wasn't planning to
except that when I put out my top 10
movies of 2016 I had a number of people
both in the comments and message me
directly saying why wasn't fantastic
beasts and where to find them in there
so I am doing a separate video
explaining why it's not in there now
before I launch into this please
understand I'm not saying the movie was
flat-out bad people that have this thing
of if you leave something out of your
top 10 they go why did you hate this I
didn't hate it however I do have a lot
of issues with it and I'm gonna kind of
get into all of that but let's start
with the positive stuff and just for a
bit of context I love Harry Potter I
have read all the books I own all the
movies it's great stuff and I loved and
I was happy to come back to this world
and it's very nice coming back to this
world I'll always be happy to come back
to the Wizarding World it's just it's
wonderful and it's fun and there's some
really good performances in here the
highlights for me are the characters of
Jacob and Queenie especially together
because their chemistry together is
wonderful but even individually they're
great and they're fun and they're
lovable and they make me smile and for
me they were the hi I wish more of the
movie was about them if I'm being honest
in terms of visual representation the a
lot of the creatures are very cool the
little platypus looking guy was adorable
he was terrific I also as much as it is
kind of derivative of Doctor Who the
whole bigger on the inside thing I do
like the case and the way there's sort
of this whole animal Preservation Hall
inside there in the way that was set up
and visually it was really cool I liked
that uhm but yeah I've got some big
problems and we'll start with Eddie
Redmayne as Newt Scamander now he's not
bad in the role he he is fine but it
he's not any Redmayne is good actor I
don't think he's a good leading man
though and there is a difference for a
leading man in a traditional leading man
role cuz obviously Eddie Redmayne has
been the lead in some films before but
not as a traditional leading man I mean
he was the lead and you know playing
Stephen Hawking you know in the Danish
girl very much not a traditional leading
part but he doesn't work as a
traditional leading man because I I
really do think there's a certain
quality that's really hard to define
that I think a leading man in a
traditional leading man type of role
needs to have and that is just charisma
watchability just this sense that you
don't want to take your eyes off of me
you just want to stay with them and
Eddie Redmayne just doesn't have that he
plays the part fine there's nothing
wrong with the way he portrays it but I
think just lacking that sort of Jennison
qua kind of hurts it by the fact that he
is the lead of the movie and almost the
whole time I was going can we can we
stick with Jacob in Queenie Oh with will
now we'll get back to Newt I suppose
he's the main guy and I when I examine
that feeling this was what I came up
with the other big thing for me is this
I can really segment this movie pretty
cleanly cuz the first two acts are one
thing and the third act is something
else altogether now the first two acts
are basically what the title implies
they're looking for the creatures
they're capturing the creatures they are
putting them back in the case and it's
light and it's fun and it's enjoyable
and it's cut it's kind of like the
closest thing we're gonna have to a live
action Pokemon movie really and that was
all good night enjoyed and then switched
gears into a much heavier action or
gated implications of a dark future
third act and I didn't care I mean the
first thing is it's jarring for me at
least it was pretty it was a pretty
jarring shift because it's like it's
like the first two accidents movie feel
like they would have been right at home
with the first two maybe three Harry
Potter movies you know with that lighter
feel oh you know we're going to school
and in this case you know we're
collecting the creatures and then they
get the last creature and all of a
sudden the third act feels like it's out
of one of the last movies in the Harry
Potter series you know where
everything's dark and dour and all big
huge stakes and I'm it's there's a
reason that the Harry Potter films took
eight movies to get from that whimsical
starting place to that dark ending place
this tries to do it all in one film and
the transition doesn't work now I will
grant that part of the problem may have
been just my experience going to watch
it and by that I mean I had to see it in
3d it was the the time that I was
available to see it it was a 3d showing
and unfortunately at the time I got
there got stuck and lousy seating sort
of way off to the side sort of cocked it
a weird angle which is not a good angle
to view a movie at all it's certainly
not a good angle to view a 3d movie at a
movie like this you really shouldn't see
in 3d because especially towards the end
this is it's very dark lighting that
never works well in 3d so I had kind of
a bad visual experience watching this
thing and it is possible that if I'd had
better seating for that third act that
it would have worked better I tend to
not think so though because my problems
are all your structure and tone and
story I didn't I had issues with my
problems weren't that I was visually
bored the fact that I couldn't tell what
was going on was a problem but it wasn't
the overriding one I mean unless the
visuals were so spectacular that it just
overrode the part of my brain that was
picking apart the story then I probably
would still have these same issues and
cuz that whole ending would be obscurest
just it was sound and noise as far as I
was I need to talk about the obscurest
too because the movie did something
would that twist of who the obscurest
was that I hated I didn't hate the twist
I didn't hate the reveal of who it was
but I hate the way the movie did it
because it's not a real twist they
cheated and by that I mean we have never
seen an obscurus before in Harry Potter
we've never had reference to it we don't
know what it is we don't know what the
so this movie is going to tell us the
rules in it and it lays those out and it
lays out oh you know these children that
are obscure asses or have a obscurus in
the however it works
they don't live past that it was ten at
I saw the weeks ago let's say ten they
don't live past ten and then it was like
ooh but it's not this little girl we
were letting you think it was it was
this guy who's like 18 or 19 Oh big
surprise like you didn't surprise me you
lied to me you cheated with your initial
knowledge not being correct that's not a
twist as a viewer I'm taking your word
at the rules you're giving me so if
you're just lying to me that's not
playing fair and then there was just the
other stuff towards the end and Colin
Farrell turned out to be Johnny Depp but
honestly going forward I would have
preferred Colin Farrell and I just
wasn't invested in that whole thing you
know what I was thinking about that
whole third act wow this is a lot of
damage how would the heck are they gonna
cover all this up and not have the
mughals fine sorry no Maja's find out
about all this and then they really kind
of give us a very cheap deus ex machina
to get through that so whoo well yeah
it's not a bad movie but it for a lot of
very fundamental reasons it didn't quite
work for me and you know ultimately I
think I kind of I kind of land on this
one the same way I did on Batman V
Superman now to be clear this is a
better movie than Batman V Superman was
but I kind of land in the same place
which is that this film in and of itself
I don't really care for I'm not really
gonna want to see you again but I am
intrigued enough by what it gives me
anyone when it sets up for the future
that I will come back for future
installments and hope that they do it
better so that's sort of where I end up
now obviously lots of people seem to
really like this judging by the people
who were surprised it wasn't in my top
10 so if you love this great awesome
that's terrific
I didn't you know it happens so did you
see fantastic beasts and where to find
them what were your thoughts on it
whatever they were drop something down
in the comments let's talk about it
don't forget to hit that little bell
down there so you get notifications when
I put up new videos check out the
council of geeks podcast available on
iTunes and stitcher follow me on Twitter
at council of geeks i'm doing all of
these out of order now for some reason
until next time this council is
adjourned